hello porto
how are you
for some reason and i will never
understand this they like to give me the
slot immediately after the party the
night before
so uh good morning i hope you're all
doing okay out there and uh welcome to
fractals factories and fast food so uh
this is a talk about all kinds of things
it's also i've been told it is the most
appropriate use of the poop emoji that
has ever been seen in a conference talk
so look out for that
this is me dylan bt i do interesting
things with computers and code and
software i run versatile which is a
company i started in 2020 to do lots of
speaker travel and training worst
business plan ever so that's finally
actually sort of kicking off and doing
its thing
i'm a microsoft mvp i run the london.net
user group in london where i'm from and
i also once invented a programming
language as a joke in a bar that got
implemented by people on the internet
and now it's a real programming language
so if any of you has ever been on
linkedin and you want to apply for all
those sweet rock star programmer jobs
they advertise you can learn rockstar at
code codewithrockstar.com
and uh the fun thing about rockstar is
that all your programs are also heavy
metal songs so even if your code doesn't
work you can still sing it so it's got a
nice bit of redundancy built into it
that way and uh today we are going to
talk about networks now networks are
absolutely everywhere networks are how
we move value and stuff and information
and uh fuel and energy from one place to
another and uh you know we have you look
at the world around us there are
transportation networks there's road
networks telecoms networks but then
there are networks of data there are
networks of information there are
networks within our bodies there are
about five different systems in the
human body all of which can be treated
and modeled and analyzed as a network in
some sense now
this talk started out as can we tell the
story
of a slice of pizza
when you go on your phone and you order
some food and it comes to the door what
actually needed to happen to make that
possible like how much stuff did we have
to evolve and invent
for that to be a thing that we can do
now i love pizza i love food i love uh
i've only had one francesinia so far
this week but i'm sure i can get in two
and maybe a third before i go home
tomorrow um you know i absolutely i love
food and i love convenience and i hate
making phone calls
so the idea that you can push a button
on your screen and somebody brings pizza
to your house like that is just one of
the best things that human beings have
ever invented and the key thing in that
observation
is that they bring it here they bring it
to your house all of the convenience you
know amazon and doordash and
deliveroo and just eat and takeaway.com
all these kinds of things they have this
sort of definition of convenience which
is we'll bring it to your door you know
they won't bring it upstairs i mean
maybe that's the future i can't even
bother to get out of bed today but i
still want pizza and they'll actually
let themselves in and come on up but you
know this is the kind of definition this
threshold if it gets to your door and
that's
what we understand convenience to be now
we're going to talk a lot about networks
and in software and mathematics networks
are very tightly coupled to the idea of
something called a graph now we don't
have enough words in english for all the
crazy stuff that computer people keep
coming up with because you know you talk
about graphs there are different kinds
of graphs you get graphs you get in
maths and you get graphs you see on the
news and you get these kinds of graphs
because in mathematics a graph is a
collection of things
and relationships between the things
that fundamentally is all that a graph
is so
what we are going to do now we're
talking about this is sort of graph
theory definition has nothing to do with
graphql i told you there were too many
words um and we are going to take a
moment and we are going to look at how
we can model some of these ideas about
networks and convenience now
my house at home where i spent most of
the last two years i have a room
upstairs which is my office and my
office is connected to the landing and
then the landing in my house that is
connected to a bunch of other rooms
there's a bathroom there's a bedroom i
can get to the stairs and the stairs get
me to the hallway and the hallway gets
me to the kitchen the living room
and outside and then outside gets me to
pizza roma which is the place around the
corner that does a really good pizza and
outside gets me to the sydney opera
house and outside gets me to the empire
state building
and you're sort of looking at this and
going well yeah
but
that doesn't really help
um and the reason is we haven't defined
the nature of these relationships we
haven't actually said no we're modeling
one particular kind of relationship
between these objects so we need to add
a legend to this diagram so there it is
the legend is the the orange things
rooms in my house and the lines are
places i can walk to and bare feet
like places i don't need to put shoes on
because really that's convenience isn't
it like if you got to put shoes on not
too much effort if you can do it without
shoes that's convenient that's why we
bring things to the door and so now we
can update our graph and we can take
these things out and we have introduced
a boundary here the things inside the
blue they're convenient and the things
outside the blue they are inconvenient
and so we've used this idea of graph
theory to introduce this threshold of
convenience which gives us a way of kind
of talking about well what do we need to
solve here what are the problems that
we're interested in
now we're going to backtrack a little
bit we're going to go back in time to
about 1999
because in 1999 i was in my second year
of studying computer science here this
is the university of southampton on the
south coast of england where i i had a
lot of fun and i learned a lot of stuff
about linux that i've never used in my
day job and in my final year i lived
here
specifically i lived here
and the computer science department was
here it was very very close it was about
i think about 300 meters that distance
to walk it now the internet existed
in 1999 you know we had it and we had
email and we had the web and we were
just kind of figuring out hey
maybe we could do stuff with the
internet which isn't just text now you
know we didn't really have broadband and
stuff but
we had this
we had backstreet boys and we had shania
twain and we had will smith doing the
millennium and we had s club party and
uh we had napster file sharing
and this was a big deal because suddenly
there was all this music on the internet
that you could get even if you hadn't
paid for it which was awesome if you
were a student with no money who liked
music now the interesting thing we had
internet at home but it was dial-up it
was 56 kilobit dial-up shared between me
and the three other people who lived in
my house
and so i actually calculated the
threshold because the computer science
department here they had a t1 connection
that was a 1.5 megabit internet you know
that was a big deal and i worked out
that uh i could walk to the department i
could download stuff onto my i o mega
zip disc and i could walk back and the
latency of that journey that was a four
megabyte round trip
any file bigger than four megabytes it
was quicker to put shoes on walk around
the corner download the file put it on
the zip disk walk back again and take
the shoes off again than it was to just
sit at home and wait for it four
megabytes that was the threshold now
most pop songs you know mp3 is about a
megabyte a minute most pop songs were
like you know three four minutes because
that's what plays well on the radio so
if i want to download any prog rock
where all the songs are like six seven
eight minutes i was putting shoes on
that day you know now at some point they
had a problem with the security on the
back door of that building
and we had to go the long way around
and that detour
increased it to an eight megabyte round
trip
and so suddenly it was like well i guess
i'm downloading the new porcupine tree
album here because i don't want to walk
all the long way around
now that t1 connection there um this was
kind of the catchment area because you
know this was the days when like i said
people were starting to get dial up
internet at home so you could do your
emails and you know browse the the web
as it existed now you remember this is
before we invented javascript frameworks
and stuff so the web was a very very
different place but that connection
there that that circle that served about
a thousand people i reckon about a
thousand people probably got their
internet from the t1 connection in the
computer science building
but to do that they had to go there they
had to get up put shoes on leave the
house go down there and then they could
use this this glorious bandwidth and
download all the stuff that they wanted
and then a couple of years later back
we got this
they don't recognize one of these these
were like the biggest thing in the world
for about 18 months and then they just
vanished this was the first generation
of adsl modems that were rolled out in
the in the uk i think in a couple of
other places in europe as well and uh
this thing would give you 576k
of bandwidth that's nearly half a
megabit right now the amazing thing
about these modems is uh the cable that
runs into my house
looks like this
and it's probably been there there are
places in the uk where this cable was
put in in the 1960s and it's still there
and you've got two pairs of wires
and one pair of wires there is actually
used for voltage you know if any of you
still has a landline telephone at home
um that thing doesn't use the mains
electricity the telephone network has
its own power grid so that your phone
will still ring even if the power is out
so one pair of these wires here the
orange pair they carry 50 volts of dc
current so don't strip that wire with
your teeth or it's very very tingly i
can tell you that but the other pair we
have one pair of cables
and the challenge was
can we use that one pair of cables to
get broadband into people's houses now
if you look at the way a phone network
works you go out in the street and
you'll see these little metal boxes
sometimes they'll be up on a pole
sometimes they're on the street
sometimes they're underground but each
one of these serves about a hundred
different residences and businesses and
then you know you take these and then
these are all connected together to an
upstream phone exchange and then the
upstream phone exchanges those are all
connected together to central exchanges
and eventually you get to the point
where you have one of these in portugal
it's connected to the one across the
border in spain and then one in spain
connects to paris and paris connects to
london and that's how we get originally
phone calls from you know where i live
to where you live
and so the question is on the one hand
this stuff sucks
the telephone network is two wires that
have been there since the 1960s
on the other hand it's there it exists
this technology is already installed so
when they started rolling out broadband
what they did was they rolled out the
high bandwidth fiber connections into
the green box on the corner
because they'd worked out they could get
about
probably about eight megabits was the
limit at the time now the limit there
the challenge the reason why domestic
broadband has got faster and faster and
faster they haven't upgraded the cables
they've upgraded the backbone network
that gets the signal as far as the green
metal box on the corner
but fundamentally what has got better is
the quality of the equipment that we use
in our homes to get onto that broadband
network now there is fiber broadband i
got very excited when i saw this on the
thing around the corner of my eyes i'm
like look they got five here that
doesn't mean that the fiber is actually
gonna run all the way to my house what
they've done is they've run fiber from
the internet backbone as far as that
cabinet and then there's about two
kilometers of copper now in the 2001
when i first got broadband that little
bluefish modem thing that wasn't
terribly powerful because computers were
not as powerful as they are today it was
expensive and they could get
kilobits up to about two k's if you
lived more than two k's away from your
phone exchange you didn't get to play
broadband that wasn't the thing that we
did but we've got better and better at
building systems that can get more and
more bandwidth out of the same cable if
you go online now um this is the the
asus rtax82u
and you know it looks like a kind of
futuristic space hovercraft or something
because that's how you sell hardware to
gamers and this thing has got a 1.5 gig
triple core processor 256 megs of ram
512 megabytes of uh sorry flash storage
and 512 megs of ram and it costs about
200 euros you know this is like a
hundred times more powerful than the
computer that i had to download
backstreet boys onto and this is just a
modem you know but because it can do
that it can do all sorts of incredibly
sophisticated error correction it can
extract much more bandwidth from the
noisy signal that you get over these uh
two kilometers of copper wire and so
that's how we get to the point where
over the last couple of years i've been
doing online training i've been doing
talks like this live over the internet
my house in london i have about 48
megabits of bandwidth and it's still
running over those two little copper
wires that have been there since uh i
think my house 1981 is when it was built
so that's when the the cable was put in
and as far as i know no one's ever
upgraded it but that just works not
because we made the network any better
but because we have invested all of this
in making technology that can get more
signal out of the same cable because the
alternative
is we need to run better cable
everywhere
and that's not just a question of
previously you'd run one cable now you
need to run 100 some of those cables are
going to have to go into listed
buildings where you're not allowed to
just turn up and drill holes in the wall
some of them are going to go to
apartment buildings or it's like got
someone up on the 27th floor do we have
a ladder that big no we don't so that
last mile challenge or i guess the last
kilometer challenge if you're in the
rest of the world that is a real
headache when it comes to rolling out
any kind of network infrastructure
because it's really easy to get
something to a point where if people are
going to put on shoes and walk five
minutes around the corner there's one in
the neighborhood but actually getting it
into people's homes that is a big deal
now
in my uh router at home
as well as the uh you know incredibly
clever signal processing that talks to
the old telephone network i have a sim
card um actually anyone here got 5g on
their phones
because i have 5g at home but it doesn't
work because there's no 5g coverage but
i have 4g which means i can get good
enough broadband good enough bandwidth
to actually do live zoom talks and stuff
at one point i unplugged the network
cable from my modem uh just to check
that the failover worked and then the
doorbell went and i went to get my
package and i forgot about it and i
forgot about it for two days and i
didn't realize my whole house was
running over a 4g sim card for two days
until i went to log into azure and it
said your ip address is not on the list
here and i'm like is it as i'm oh oh and
i was like wow i did an entire
conference yesterday
on a sim card and it just worked you
know this is some pretty amazing
technology and this is how we do netflix
and amazon prime and you know spotify
and zoom calls and online gaming and all
that kind of stuff
and it's how we can order pizza
so we're gonna go now we're gonna build
up the pizza from the ground up we're
gonna look at the networks that are
involved in making the pizza happen so
we got the networks we can use to order
the pizza now we need the networks that
we use to make a pizza now pizza we're
gonna start at the bottom pizza base
made from bread dough most bread dough
most flour in the world comes from
canada canada is one of the world's
biggest exporters of uh flour and you
know grain and that kind of stuff now
you probably have a picture in your head
when i say you know imagine a farmer
you're probably thinking you know a guy
with a big straw hat maybe a little
piece of straw like we had in the kids
picture books
farming doesn't work like that anymore
um for a long time for most of human
history
one person working
seven days a week ten hours a day could
produce enough food to feed 1.5 people
so if everyone in your family was
healthy and all of you were working on
the farm or you were you know hunting or
you were gathering you had enough food
that you know you could look after
grandma who's getting a bit old and she
can't work the field anymore you've got
enough to feed your kids maybe you've
got enough to get you through the winter
and you know keep some saved up in case
somebody gets injured and there are
parts of the world where life is still
like that where if your family wants to
eat all of you are working on gathering
food all day every single day of your
adult lives
but industrialization the industrial
revolution we started kind of moving
those numbers and by the 1950s we had
mechanization we had mechanical tractors
one farmer could feed about 20 people so
suddenly the other 19 people are like i
can start doing other stuff i can go and
study mathematics i can invent computers
i can invent javascript frameworks you
know all these kinds of things today
we're at the point where one farmer you
know big industrialized farming like
this each farmer produces enough food
for about 500 people now on the one hand
that's pretty amazing because now all
the other those 499 other people who
don't have to farm they can go and do
all kinds of other things with their
lives and they can make art and music
and invent broadband routers and all
this kind of stuff but modern farming is
seriously high-tech like take all of the
amazing stuff with autonomous vehicles
and mesh sensor networks the stuff
you're not allowed to do in the street
because that's the public street and you
might hurt somebody farms are private
land
farms are these huge swathes of land
that are owned by someone and are not
available to the public and they're like
we will do literally anything here that
will give us a competitive edge when it
comes to guaranteeing the output from
you know farming's expensive you pour a
huge amount of money into the land and
the equipment you want to get as much
out of that as you can so
they have networks where there will
literally be you know satellites thermal
imaging combined with infrared cameras
on drones that will go and go that bit
that corner of that field that looks a
little warmer than it should be we need
a tiny bit more water there that bit
that's a little bit cooler than it
should be we're probably watering that
bit too much and they will feed this
into a sensor network uh there are gps
based planting systems now that plant
sugar beet you know sugar beet starts a
tiny seed ends up a thing about this big
and then when they go and plow the field
they can put the plow blade within a
centimeter of the crop each side without
damaging the actual beet itself and so
it gets you know earth around it with
nutrients and everything and all of this
is because we have these kinds of
precision networks now there's a there's
a thing called dot
and this is dot
dot is basically a massive
diesel-powered radio controlled car
that you can put accessories on to
like you know when you're a kid and you
go to the toy store and you can get like
the toy which has all the different
interchangeable parts this is dot but
it's doing that on a farming scale it
has uh equipment for doing crop seeding
it has equipment for doing irrigation it
has equipment for doing harvesting and
these things are real you know it's got
an eight and a half liter diesel engine
so it's a huge truck and they just drive
around the farms all day every day you
know it's planting stuff harvesting
stuff driven by mesh sensor networks and
uh little snippets i think most of the
like autonomy automation for that thing
is done using python at the moment so
this is the world we actually live in we
have these huge farms they turn out a
couple of thousand tons of wheat every
year all that wheat gets uh some of it
is processed on site so the crop is
processed turned into flour some of it
they'll just export somewhere else
and it ends up on one of these it ends
up on a container ship um you'll
remember last year the ever given got
wedged sideways in the suez canal and it
was like a traffic jam but there was
like a traffic jam of container ships
that couldn't get from uh you know china
taiwan singapore couldn't get to europe
through the suez canal and my brother
ordered a graphics card and it took six
months to arrive because of that traffic
jam it's like my graphics card is still
stuck somewhere off the coast of egypt
and maybe they think it might get
through next month now
international shipping
these things containers
if you can get your stuff into one of
these
it can go just about anywhere in the
world this is like the tcp packets of
physical stuff we have this
transportation network that's like we
don't care what's in the container we've
got a machine that'll take the container
load it up put it on the truck then we
got a machine that'll take it off the
truck put it on the ship we've got a
machine takes it off the ship puts it on
the train we got a machine at the other
end we'll take it off the train put it
on the truck it'll rock up outside your
house and it's your problem again you
know going if anybody's ever like moved
house across continents like you've
moved from one continent to another at
some point you probably got one of these
with all your stuff in it because at
that point they're just shipping packets
big metal packets this is the standard
unit and again you know truck driving is
absolutely vital the road transportation
network is we rely on it all this stuff
you know pizza and graphics cards all
these kinds of things and that's
somewhere where there's an awful lot of
disruption going on i wanna show you
this this is vera
and uh vera looks like something out of
science fiction vera looks like
something out of blade runner
vera is an autonomous truck
and vera is real
vera is working right now it's a
collaboration between volvo and a
scandinavian shipping company called
dfds seaways and this vehicle is taking
containers between the dfds freight
depot and the cargo port in gothenburg
and part of that journey involves
driving
on a public highway so we right now we
have these autonomous vehicles that are
taking shipping containers out of a port
driving them along the road and taking
them to where they can be loaded onto
trucks now on the one hand we need this
you know human beings there are more
people than ever before and our appetite
for stuff is just going up and up and up
and uh i don't know how many of you are
familiar with the brexit and all the
joys we have going on with that
apparently right now there is a 27-hour
tail back to get trucks through the port
of dover in the uk to process all the
paperwork um and the news isn't talking
about it but if you read any blogs from
polish truck drivers they're not very
happy about this so we need the
infrastructure you know we need the
capacity we need more stuff but
this is also going to be a massive
social disrupter there's something like
three and a half million people in the
united states right now who drive a
truck that's their living that's how
they make their money and feed their
kids and everything and if you drive a
truck the law says that you can work a
max i think it's 10 hours in the u.s and
then you have to have a 10-hour break so
these huge trucks spend half their time
parked while the driver is resting or
sleeping we roll out autonomous trucks
that are like nope we're electric we run
silently 24 hours a day seven days a
week three and a half million americans
suddenly out of work
you know what politician is going to run
for office on that ticket because it's
not going to happen anytime soon but we
don't have enough truck drivers to go
around the ones that we do have they're
incredibly politically important because
if they don't vote for you you're not
going to win but it's still not enough
to go around so
this is the network that gets our pizza
to us the flower comes from canada the
uh if you have mozzarella you know where
most mozzarella in europe comes from
denmark
denmark is the biggest exporter of
mozzarella uh pineapples here probably
from costa rica uh tomatoes that go on
these are probably from actually
portugal is one of the big exporters of
tomatoes the netherlands is another one
if you got shrimp or seafood on your
pizza that almost certainly went through
indonesia so we have this massive global
distribution network of stuff coming in
from all over the world and it ends up
here and that is just one of the
networks that goes in here we've got the
power network because you can't really
cook pizza without lights to see what
you're doing so they need power we have
the gas network because pizza ovens
electric doesn't really cut it you need
burning gas to get up to the right
temperature or you need trucks full of
charcoal if you're doing you know
charcoal ovens um you need data you need
the banking network when you pay for
your pizza a little bit of that money
goes to the well all of it goes to the
pizza company and then some of that goes
to the takeaway company but the pizza
company use it to pay the flour company
and the flour company use it to pay the
trucking company and the trucking
company use it to pay the shipping
company so when you order pizza online a
couple of cents of that is going to the
people who own these massive container
ships that they're bringing all over the
world so we have this fantastic
coordinated system of all of these
different networks all converging and
they make your extra large stuffed crust
pepperoni with extra mozzarella cheese
and pineapple
and it ends up here
on the back of a bike with a guy going
up and down your road because he can't
find your address and you're looking at
the window gun is that my pizza is that
that must yeah he looks lost eventually
you go and you're like hey
pizza and i was like no no
oh okay sorry um this is one of the big
problems and uh
the difficulty with we talked about you
know the last mile or last kilometer
infrastructure with installing networks
installing fiber optic cable and stuff
but at least that they've only got to do
it once like if the engineers coming to
install your fiber you're probably going
to try and make sure they know where you
live with stuff happens every day you
know deliveries and the mail and pizza
showing up
we have a problem in that addresses are
complicated now joel spalsky has this
thing spolsky's law of leaky
abstractions all non-trivial
abstractions to some degree are leaky
now we have this idea that you can write
down somebody's address
and
then you can find their house
now uh imagine this is a map of my house
this is not a map of my house because my
house is in a weird place and i don't
want to put a map of where i live on the
internet in case i upset anybody who
invests in crypto because those people
look dangerous to me
but my house is in the wrong place
my house is on a street that's about
three kilometers long it's right in the
middle and it's number seven so if you
start at this end we're like
what that's number two hundred that's
number four hundred number seven is in
the middle the area i live was uh
basically bombed during world war ii and
then when they rebuilt it they just made
up the street numbers as they went along
so we have this uh convention in most
parts of uh you know europe and the west
that uh we have a street and the first
house on the street is number one and
number two is opposite number one and
then there's number three and number
four five six all the way along the
street so you need to find number one
i'd say it's probably at this end start
there work your way along if you need to
find number 15 it'll be between number
13 and number 17.
actually i noticed last night we got
back to the hotel after the dinner um
and uh rob richardson was like you know
the way the hotel room number's like
you're in 14 and there's 16 but over
there that's 12 and that's 15. i'm like
he's like there's no 13. no room 13 in
the hotel because it's unlucky so
they've messed up the numbering system
just in one corridor of one hotel now
you'd think that maybe there's some
things we can rely on when it comes to
addressing like uh you know if you know
which city you're going for and you know
the name of the street right
well no there are 15 streets in london
called high street so if you write
number one high street london there are
15 different places that are like yeah
that's me that's absolutely fine uh you
won't get negative house numbers right
like you've got to start at one and work
your way up
well yeah mostly
this
is a cocktail bar again it's in london
quite near where i live and this used to
be a public toilet so it didn't have an
address because why would a toilet have
an address and the building next to it
is number one aldrich that's the lyceum
theater where they've been showing the
lion king forever so when they turn this
toilet into a bar they're like we need
an address and they'll that's one that's
two that's three
i guess we're zero
but you can't put zero as a number so
the name of this building is zero zero
aldwich and that's the thing that they
have to put in the addresses because no
database in the world will allow you to
put zero aldwich and uh in a town called
newbury which is just outside london
there is a minus one priory road because
they already had zero and they built
another house next to it and again the
name of the house is minus one priory
road that's the name of the place and uh
yeah so these are the kind of
abstractions that we are we're trying to
deal with when we address stuff now
it probably seems obvious to us that of
course you you know you build the street
and then you give all the buildings
addresses
and the streets are the things which
have names in japan they use a
completely different system if you want
to go here this is a 257 maranucci what
you do is you get a marinucci and uh you
probably in the days before google maps
what you do is you find a policeman and
you'd say hey where is building number
two now building number two would be the
second building that got built in
marinute or the second block
so the first city block that got built
there that would be block one the second
block would be block two it might be on
the other side of the district it might
be right next door the third block is
block number three then you go to
somebody who knows their way around
block number two and you say hey
which one of these buildings was built
fifth
because the first building to go up that
would be two one marinucci the second
building would be two two marinucci say
like that one that one there okay that
one that one was built fifth so it got
to number fifty not gonna do it like
hello uh which business moved in here
seventh please
because the whole addressing system is
assigned chronologically numbers are
given out as they are needed so the
first block is one the second block is
two the first building is one the second
building is to the first inhabitant
first people to move in they get number
one
the streets don't have names why would
you name the street the street is the
gap between the important parts you know
doesn't make any sense you give the
names and numbers to the bits that
people care about and of course that
system seems completely obvious until
somebody who has grown up with the
western addressing system is lost in
tokyo going i don't know where i am and
none of these streets have names but you
know you flip it around and somebody who
has grown up with this system visits
london or paris and they're like how do
you live here none of the blocks have
names like why did you name the gaps so
we have these two completely
counter-intuitive systems and so you
know nerds like us are like you know
what we need here
we need synthetic keys relying on
natural data is not good enough
let's invent the postal code
and you'd think we couldn't really screw
that up right like how hard can it be
it's the postal code it's designed so
you can deliver post so you have a code
and that should tell the post person
where to take the post now on the one
hand this is one building
in wales this is the building where the
uk government runs all of its driver and
vehicle licensing so your driver's
license registration form for your car
they have 11 postcodes that go to the
same building
because one of them is for vehicle
registration one is for driver licenses
one of them is for a personalized
license plate so these all go physically
to the same place but they've got 11
different postcodes then if you go over
here
to uh the university of warwick
there are something like i think there's
about 1500
different addresses that have the same
postal code because they assigned this
code to
all of the student residences so there's
about no it's 1500 people there are 1500
people and offices and you know
professors and things all living in this
one area and all of them share the same
postcode so postcodes nice idea didn't
work we managed to mess that one up
because you know it looked like it it
was gonna work and then we just
didn't quite get it right
so let's go further well like it's okay
we don't actually need codes anymore we
know where we are we have gps we all
have a little thing in our pocket that
is literally talking to outer space 24
hours a day seven days a week we can use
gps to find out where we are and so you
ping one of your friends you're like hey
yeah coffee would be great
meet me at fifty point four four seven
two nine three two north thirty point
five two yada yada west in half an hour
and if you do this to normal people they
go what
because you know gps coordinates to get
down to a level where you can actually
meet someone for coffee you need a huge
amount of precision just you know if you
take off the decimal point you're
talking about uh one square nautical
mile of a longitudinal latitude and
that's a pretty big area you know it
covers a good chunk of downtown porto
now
there are still companies coming up with
some fairly innovative solutions to
solve and address this kind of thing one
of them is a company called what three
words and what three words has divided
planet earth up into three by three
meter squares which is kind of small
enough that unless you're at the front
of like a lincoln park concert you can
probably see whether your friend is here
or not and then they have given every
single one of these squares a code now
this is kind of a fun idea and i really
like what they've done with it it does
have one tiny little pitfall that
perhaps they did not anticipate which is
that words have meanings so i went on
last night and i punched in the
alfandega conference center where we are
now and i was like you know that's a
pretty big building now do you want to
go during a pandemic to a conference
that is at mouth asking transmit you
know you think that's a good nah okay so
let's have a look at another one
trust wasps ever
that by the way that's pretty much
exactly where i am stood right now
because that block is this building and
that's kind of the end of room one uh do
i trust wasps ever no i don't like wasps
wasps are nasty and they don't do
anything useful
misfits requested event
did we did you did i
i mean i couldn't wait for ndc to come
back and you know maybe i'm one of the
misfits who requested the event so
eventually i thought you know what if
we're going to use the the what three
words here data indeed hobbies i think
that's a nice yeah you want to come to
ndc it's going to be here data indeed
hobbies because that's like a nice
balance so i think you know we can we
can pick a what three words for that but
we can only do that because we got a lot
of space so we got a lot of different
grid squares in here to play with so we
have all these high-tech and low-tech
solutions for how to locate a point in
space where somebody might have ordered
a pizza from and uh
you're sat there doorbell rings you're
like ah pizza and at that point a whole
new set of networks kicks in
now uh some of you might be familiar
with a software architectural pattern
called cqrs the command query
responsibility separation or segregation
did you know the human body uses cqrs
we have two different nervous systems we
have the sensory nervous system network
and we have the motor nervous system
network and the sensory one is the one
that goes ding dong oh i hear the
doorbell and i thought i heard a moped
and i can see there's someone outside
and i think i can smell grilled cheese
and so that is the that's the query
input and then at that point it issues a
command via a separate network it's like
you need to get your ass up off the sofa
and go and open the door because there
is pizza here we have these five sensory
networks feeding data and input into the
human body and then you know when they
get in there your brain analyzes all
this stuff and figures it out now the
sensory networks in the human body are
astonishing um our eyes have you ever
like taken your laptop outside on a
sunny day
and you just can't read the screen
because it's too bright and you're like
but last night when i was inside with
the lights out my laptop was too bright
i had to turn it down um our eyes can
cope with an astonishing range of
magnitude of brightness our ears can do
the same thing you know we can hear
someone like you know dropping a marble
on the other side of a massive warehouse
if there's no other noise in there but
we can also go down the front at a
really loud rock concert and we can hear
all the different notes and pick those
out of the music we can distinguish
scientists think it's something like a
trillion different smells
like they've done analyses where they've
taken like 128 different compounds and
combined them and got a bunch of
volunteers to go yeah i think i know
what that one is and this one is that
one with a little bit of that added to
it and you know extrapolating from this
data set this was a rockefeller
university 2014 was where they did the
study and they're like yeah we think it
might be like a trillion like literally
we can't do the experiment because
people don't live long enough for us to
test all the things we want to test on
what one person can smell and that is
just one of these networks
so you go to the door and you get your
pizza and you take a bite of it and you
know your taste network gives you this
ah that's really good grilled cheese and
then the uh you know the digestive
network kicks in and it starts breaking
down that pizza into nutrients and you
know fat there's some bits which you
absorb immediately your body will digest
the sugar out of that some of it your
body will store for the winter because
uh obviously we can't get pizza in
winter so we need to put on a little bit
of extra padding to get through the the
lean months there um some of it ends up
becoming waste you know now
the circulatory system that takes the
sugar and takes the you know the energy
from that
that starts off with this thing here
this is your aorta that's a bat this big
it's a blood vessel maybe three four
centimeters in diameter that's about
this long and then that just branches
out and out and out almost exactly like
the broadband networks we talked about
the beginning and then you get down to
the capillaries in the tips of your
fingers that's the two kilometers of
copper wire that you can't use it for
anything major but because the distance
there is so short it's just enough to
get that energy to where it's needed and
to bring the stuff back in the other
direction
and
we end up with waste you know there's a
fair chunk there's the box your pizza
came in you need to get rid of that
somehow there's also uh the uh
shall we say the biological packaging
that the pizza comes in and uh well put
it this way would you rather live in a
house where you could get pizza but you
didn't have a toilet or would you rather
live in a house where you had a toilet
but you had to go around the corner to
get pizza which one of those would you
rather was round the corner and share
with the rest of the folks in your
neighborhood because that's a relatively
recent invention only within the last
hundred years have we had plumbing and
sewer systems to dispose of all the bits
of pizza that our body doesn't need now
we could go even further we are still
this whole model is reliant on the idea
that uh all these ingredients have to be
farmed and you know fished and
cultivated and then physically assembled
and put together but really
what we're talking about here is
molecules we are just talking about
stuff that your body enjoys eating and
that gives you fuel could we get to the
uh the whole idea of the star trek
replicator where you just have something
in your house that is going to go in and
say yeah i want a stuffed crust pizza
it's like yep all right give me a about
a kilo of molecules and it's just going
to assemble that for you
now one thing i never noticed in star
trek you notice how you never see anyone
do the dishes so they must have some
kind of mechanism for putting the stuff
back in to the replicators at the other
side of it and if any of you've read
this book neil stevenson's diamond age
um this is a fantastic book about
neo-victorian nanotechnology engineering
and uh the network that exists in this
book is a thing called the feed and the
feed is just molecules the feed is a
pipe running into everyone's house that
gives them raw molecules that can be
assembled into
objects and tools and toys and all this
kind of stuff and so they have mastered
nanotech engineering to the extent where
now they don't eat it that's one of the
weird things about the diamond age is
that he didn't kind of take that extra
step further but you know it does start
bringing up these questions about what
does the future of food delivery look
like now
this is a 3d printer that makes pizza
and this is real they've seen this thing
at trade shows and you know it has a
couple of nozzles fenu's got a 3d
printer at home you know you've got like
different filament well let's just
imagine that the nozzle's really wide
and the filament isn't filament it's
bread and then you have another nozzle
here which prints tomato and another
nozzle here which prints cheese
this is the coca-cola freestyle vending
machine where instead of like them
having you know a big tank of coke and a
big tank of uh what is coke's uh fruit
thing sprite and it's like no we got
like a thousand different flavors and
you can get an app for this so you can
walk into like a burger king and you can
download the app and you can be like i
want a three percent grape and two
percent blueberry and five percent
caffeine and you put a button and it'll
synthesize the soda that you just
designed there um and this thing here
the sugar bot this is a smart bakery
that uh you use an app to talk to it and
it's like yeah what do you want you want
vegan donuts you want regular chocolate
donuts and it just has all the
ingredients it synthesizes this in
software now these kind of things they
are at trade shows at the moment there
are very few people
actually using anything like this to you
know make real food for real people to
eat but
the concept has been proved
now uh something that i'm confident of
we are going to get you know stuff that
works on this basis we are going to
start seeing technology that delivers
alternatives to the idea of having to
farm things and cultivate them and
prepare them and then deliver the
finished prepared product
and i think they are going to be like
electricity like plumbing like broadband
you are going to have one of these in
your neighborhood a long time before you
have one in your house
these will be something uh there's a
vending machine in a garden station in
paris now that bakes bread and you go
and you you pay with your card and it
literally bakes you a loaf of bread and
it's open 24 7. and paris is designed
like completely divided as to whether a
machine should be allowed to bake bread
or not but you know this is we're
starting to see the first uh signs of
this happening in everyday life but
fundamentally when you have a slice of
pizza you are getting three things first
of all
you're getting fuel your body needs
calories to live second you are getting
sensations you know pizza is nice food
is nice it's part of a social rituals
but it's also an enjoyable experience
we've evolved to like food that's why we
keep eating it because that way we don't
die and uh you know as we've already
seen there is a certain amount of
byproduct involved in this whole process
that we also need to anticipate in the
design of our networks
what if we could decouple these things
what if we could be like well actually
the byproduct let's eliminate that
completely the fuel well you can get
fuel out of anything your body can
digest doesn't matter if it doesn't
taste good we could eat blue green algae
we could eat insect protein we could eat
all kinds of things which leaves the bit
in the middle which is the sensation
because you know we want food to be nice
we anticipate good meals now
the kid in this picture
is uh wearing a cochlear implant hearing
aid and the bit you can see there on the
outside that's not the clever bit that's
the battery in the transmitter there is
a tiny piece of circuitry implanted
inside his ear which is literally wiring
a microphone directly into the nerves
inside his ear
did any see that movie the sound of
metal with uh zach made a couple years
ago so that uh movie the sound design
for that one and oscar and that the bit
at the end where he turns his implants
on that shows you what or like
illustrates what that actually sounds
like so we are not at the point yet
where we can make synthetic hearing that
works as well as a normal human ear but
we are at the point where we are
literally using sensors of you know
artificial chips to put electricity into
someone's brain and their brain is then
figuring out how to turn that into
sensory input that actually improves
their quality of life and you know these
are the early steps but at this point
it's just engineering we validated the
concept we need you know better sensors
we need to understand better how the
human brain responds to electricity
but potentially you know the future of
takeaway food
is you plug yourself into the matrix you
go on your just eat app and you're like
download pizza and then you just sit and
you eat your 500 grams of locally
sourced insect protein while your brain
is going ah pepperoni this is so good
this is amazing because you know maybe
this is the future maybe we decouple the
taste sensations which mean we need all
these massive multinational networks
from the fact that we just need food to
live we synthesize the whole thing and
you order pizza directly to your brain
but as we've already seen it's difficult
enough delivering to street addresses
you send a stuffed crust pepperoni pizza
and accidentally goes to the neighbor's
ip address they are probably going to
find themselves in for one hell of a
shock
thank you folks
[Applause]
i think we we have time for questions
if there are questions
or is this everyone going i'm just going
to go and get pizza now
[Laughter]
cool
all right thank you very much enjoy the
rest of the day enjoy the rest of the
conference we're going to be doing some
fun stuff in the expo hall this evening
so stick around for the party uh going
to be doing some music lemon is running
an improvised like comedy talks thing
which sounds like it's going to be a lot
of fun so thank you everyone for coming
go and get a front of the coffee queue
and i'll see you all around take it easy
you